whoa just in time less than ten seconds
here we go
one-minute war zone rated 50 players
1750 average rating time and position
handicapped it will be adjusted
according to rating here we go 30
minutes of straight craziness oh I could
win this game so easily if you're
watching if you were watching last if
you were watching last time I could
totally make black in a very indirect
way I could end black at any second if I
really wanted to I could pull the plug I
might want to reserve that option I
might want to do it as a last ditch if
things go wrong you know the move I'm
gonna make could happen here it is the
blue chicken canvas I might hit black
with the blue chicken gambit I have it
available I could just I could just sack
the farm here I could throw pieces sack
of Queen and then play it
it could happen real soon can you want
to see one TKO watch out for the blue
chicken gambit it will get you okay okay
okay okay okay okay
my LightSquared bishop wants to rumble
he's rumbling he's rumbling with tempo
tempo gainer hit the night push the H
pawn rook g'wan
I might right at the end now that I know
I won I might just do the blue chicken
now that I know I won I'm gonna do it I
was gonna win anyway you know it I had
to do it back to Jeff I had to do it you
knew it was winning anyhow I'm only
gonna do that all I could do it again I
could do it again here only when I know
I have the win I could maybe do that
right at the end
otherwise it's cruel and unusual okay ah
the anti thunderhorse variation the one
that says let's trade palms and I say no
no no no let's not and say we did I
could do it again I could do it again
don't make me do it do not provoke the
blue chicken attack it's happening again
the night is gonna land oh this is
protected I'm on the Queen give me the G
file this is like the REM this is this
was already happening let's go dark
square bishop Oh take that take the
knight and the Queen dies she's a dead
lady get a rook x lookin pretty
why'd I do that
oh why they do that come on Queenie
back-to-back blue chicken gambits haha
what are you talking about what in the
world back to tournament they were
fearing it they have the sense that I
was gonna hit him with the King EA to
see a TKO okay there's no blue chicken
gambit here I can't I don't have
anything to fall back on right now so I
actually have to play for real my - no
don't you dare get out of there I'm
gonna try to trap you get out of there
bishop
let's go Knight be a contributor what am
i what am i doing I just dropped upon no
I didn't know pawn staircase - open it
up take that pawn he's a freebie my King
has to run like a bandit I don't want to
push my pawn I'm weakening this
structure
my knight needs to do something else
because he's stupid right where he was
what's scary time scary time why am I
not moving I don't have any time they're
moving fast
oh-oh-oh-oh move knight anywhere just
move knight ah why'd I do that
just take my bishop I want to get to the
you know the B file I don't have any
time oh I'm gonna lose on time oh no no
no no no no I want to cry I'm already
crying oh this is bad news for me
run away run fast oh there's no good
defense no come on just give me the
rooks then if you're gonna do that give
me the rooks give me the rooks and I
gotta fly I gotta fly and I can't fly
him give me the Queen I got the Queen I
got the Queen don't you calm me out give
me a check check grab a knight another
check grab upon you got to go quick
pre-move pre-move Primo's give me pawns
pac-man mode pac-man mode run run run
over here King fly fly grab a pawn push
a pawn move King grab another part Oh
back to tournament they resigned best
nineteen bunch of twelves T night 16
double those points the phantom Queen
night variation oh my heart is racing
right now
this is an adrenaline rush if you didn't
know it's an adrenaline rush it's not
just a chess game this is what you call
an adrenaline rush oh man David Blaine
David Blaine I was holding my breath
once again for what felt like seven
minutes and
what am i doing oh this happened before
I think I'm gonna actually grab that pun
and run
oh I'm on this some of this some of this
Forks or not no Forks close to it Forks
sort of actually my bishop here I'm
gonna queenside castle take the knight
that's all right oh I was ready to take
that and drop my queen
let's not and say we did Oh Oh on the
rookie in-betweener
uh-oh I'm actually up now how's the
clock situation it's good they're down
okay I mean they resign 20 19 17 I have
one point lead okay 20 a lot of time
left - lets go
Queen night let's go with the double
fianchetto what's happening here
all right Knight make your little
journey go for your little journey g6 is
your favorite square you're gonna love
that because f5 is your next square that
you're gonna fall in love with h4 h5 h6
dark squares h-file open up open up grab
the Jeep on open up this diagonal and
then give me looking for the mates
oh my Bishop's gonna get shut down I can
feel it
let's open it up before it's too late
just take my knight just take up oh
there's a deadly fork no there's not
Bishop g4 would have been good I think
oh man okay let's castle now there's
nothing going on the H file is there my
table my bishops dead why didn't they
take that they probably should have
taken that um our that the the knight a
four move No
Oh Queen takes there I'm gonna take this
actually and hope for the best
I probably shouldn't have done that okay
no I have a time edge it's all right
defend this pawn I'm not even defending
it though
check pre moves I was ready to grab that
night I think I get this guy at least
okay let me get something I'm on the
knight pod push might be good or that
okay get out of silly checks okay
they're down there way down on time
what's that Knight up - he's up to no
good get out there night get out there
Knight pre movers pre movers Murphy
movers
we're down on time 30 29 this guy's
right on my heels and so is this guy
gonzo Osama let's roll
more chats 21 more minutes of warzone
action here where you're gonna see
you're gonna have nightmares of this
structure and you're gonna be like why
does he keep them from those pawns it's
because I don't want to trade when I'm
down material let's go G file over here
just take a night that was a free night
kind of oh oh oh come on push push push
oh I don't want to open up here okay I
got to do it I think looking for my
Bishop is dead
Oh beer up right here would have been a
brutal move they missed it now I got
made threats and everything
oh let's back up before it's too late or
just take the pond that was a freak oh
this is free ok mates coming up right
here mate back on bad guy be scared be
very scared age 5 and G for a g4 h5 they
resigned back to tournament that was
pretty quick 4235 27 I have a little bit
more of a lead the King's attacker uh-oh
let's go pile up on f7 quick
I'm gonna take it maybe I should have
went to squares okay let's go e6 oh oh
oh
pac-man mode chop-chop with the check
and then come back here I didn't have to
come back there right away but I'm gonna
do it
okay a little pressure here but I should
be alright let's go here
look take SEF Queen f3 triple up uh-oh
sneaky sneaky sneaky oh I'm in trouble
man I'm in trouble why didn't I see that
I tried to be slick with an in-betweener
who got the last laugh no no no no no
don't you dare defend pond oh this is
bad news Oh even more bad news no don't
let it be man this is so dead come on
work out blunder
blunder where the blunders I'm a trouble
big trouble run for the hills run for
the hills oh there's just gonna be a
queen check and I'm a dead man
or am i I can't win this why am I still
playing I can't win this can i oh
they're just gonna go there okay can I
can I save this somehow can I save this
I should have done that pon move oh it's
a dry it's a dry it's a trial it's a dry
save did I say oh I got loud right there
sorry about that I saved a try oh D oh D
knee Wow
out of nowhere I'm gonna chalk that one
up as a win give me the rook the rook is
dead Oh pieces are falling pieces are
falling everywhere I'm actually okay now
because I'm not down on the rook it the
material is balanced but all I could
take a knight
take a knight hit a bishop it's close to
trapped taking here's no good I get the
night at the end of it okay let's go
here the pawn is pinned take I get the
other rook get the other rookie I have
no idea no idea how that happened one
minute no I had one second one minute
would be an eternity okay
if I don't say and sell myself that was
a while right there Jack pre-move and
where's the king gonna go Castle no
matter what matin to make it one if it
takes close to matin 1 still close to me
and wine if takes is he gonna be taken
well me too I've taken over here
checks see - what's the what's the scoop
here
how much time three moves Primos more
pre moves back to turn 50 six I gotta
catch this guy 69 that draw health that
guy has eight out of eight I was lucky
to even get a job just move anywhere oh
I'm doing that to Fein count on my clean
Bishop right okay yeah I'm gonna do that
soon I'm gonna fee and ket on my clean
bishop right that's gonna happen fifteen
minutes and change and I'm gonna be
sneaky and get my night I guess - f -
I'm not sure why but it seems cozy and
now launch it it's being launched no
trades the night might come here though
okay forks forks forks okay open up the
H file Oh Oh H files opened up stop the
night from playing c5 and I want to jump
into f6 I'm on the 9th and then the
bishop oh I got one piece back how's the
time how's the time situation
oh it's check and we got our mates
coming up soon tricky mates are in the
air for X pins skewers look for them
okay let's trade right here how's the
clock situation okay I could fight back
from that I think I should play b4 maybe
no I got a hangout of my night Forks
pawn push rook to c6 castle stop the
knife from playing here tricky night
castle okay double up 18 seconds I
should be able to get this Forks and
then just double up no matter what even
if it's not the best just go there might
be Bishop takes pawn we're now okay I
got a pig on the seventh it's hungry
hungry pig on push LightSquared bishop
wants to play play give a check no
matter what time burner more time
players back to term at 72 I have a lead
oh he slipped back to he slipped back as
well right there 67
all righty 13 minutes and change leave
oh okay let's not feed cattle the co
they resigned they were fearing the not
me not having those minor pieces 90 and
67 58
okay still no minor pieces what is going
on I need some minor pieces and my
opponent has a time edge to 30 second 35
okay dark squares off and I'm a dark
square bishop to take advantage of it
I'll be nice if I could get that in age
3G 4 okay you're gonna give me the H
file no you're not okay well done I
don't want you to get their night come
on move
okay oh this pawn move is gonna kill me
oh man I am in trouble or am i they gave
me some the piece back okay I'm gonna
take that queenside castle and I have I
have a good plan here I think my knight
wants to be on e4 if it's challenged
okay no no no no no no no they were
gonna chop this and that would have been
bad news for me let's come over here and
light squares where are the light
squares look at my knight
what a stupid piece oh I have a sneaky
move sneaky move uh-oh double check
leads to mate actually double check I
could get the Queen but I'm going for
the throat going for the throat it's a
matin one followed by two on h7
unavoidable right TKO double check mate
there it is that was smooth one 110 Oh
111 somebody is 111 gonzo sama okay this
is I got to keep winning here
no Queen night Queen night have to go
quick plan here go quick okay now the
center is oh wait let me do
oh I should have blocked up the center
they're gonna take no they're not okay
what do you do next stop the bishop in
the night from coming there over here
see five actually maybe I could slam the
door on the Bishop c4 and then an
expansion okay we're not having that
we're having to trade okay
pawn push here trouble maybe I should oh
I should have done this I'm gonna do it
now I get the light squares I get them
the diagonal here if they get two pawns
clean trade coming up I'm assuming I'm
gonna I'm gonna do it though I'm gonna
smash this open and get my knight I
don't want to take this pawn because
there's problems that the position opens
up I'm on the bishop
okay let's do what oh that pawns gonna
push okay let's open this up actually I
want the h-file and I have it I rook up
and over lateral movement be very scared
I'm on the knight from afar I'm gonna do
it they probably think I'm taking the
pawn sneaky Oh sneaky sneaky sneaky
sneaky let's come back over here okay
let's go let's roll how do I take that's
me that is me I needed that one that's a
quick one 130 who's in first now a 10
and change 130 112 112 112 112 is on my
heels okay who is this I don't know I
don't have time to look let's go with
this stop this should be for stuff and
let's get it in okay things are okay now
positions not gonna open up anytime soon
is it okay let's try and open it up now
H file can I get the H file I got the H
file I got play for my rook my Knight
wants to play next oh okay let's do this
I don't want the knight coming to f5
okay I guess this is gonna open up
taketake Knight right here I'm looking
to win the bishop if the knight look
okay I got the bishop
this is good it's the material count
there goes the bishop give a check the
Queen has to block I'm gonna take here
actually get another piece of material
actually the materials balance now no
it's not about material my knight wants
to go somewhere else oh he's ready to
give a check let's not do that
I should probably councils know I'm on
the knight on the pine give check if the
King goes here maybe I could take the
knight should take it the knight on our
feet you dummy
take that night it's Castle get my rep
playing it's just still good though
Oh Oh big trouble right here I guess I
had that too man that was something so
much better you just chopped the night
on f8 ok forks no matter what I'm gonna
take ok they're gonna take why'd I do
that
ok I'm on this [ __ ] up there on my
bishop ok we're gonna go with this
gobble
run grab that pond ok with check just
come over here run
what's the clock situation run run
cut the King off primo primo primo primo
back to tournament 150 151 he's got 151
I gotta get that guy are we gonna get
paired up that'll be a big game I'm glad
I ended up drawn that one game I'd I'd
be back right now are they moving what's
gone so Sam is reading what I end up
with the possibility for the blue
chicken gambit no quit trying to trade I
don't want any of that
trades would I actually be down a queen
rook in that down in that case queenside
castle let's come over here c5 I better
do something quick my opponent is flying
at me let's do this keep it closed it
take do pawn push h6 otherwise I do h6
whoa Wow there's no compensation for
this dark squares you got to get out of
there clean you're too good right there
you too well-placed okay I got this look
up and over bishop here is real good oh
okay they didn't do it
I thought bishop there could be really
really good maybe still is oh that
pounds dead
I got a trade I can't let it get here
please don't get there okay rook up and
over bishop has to go you gotta go
bishop you're too good and this nights
gonna be even better oh man
okay prepare for the worst my bishop is
there to watch over stuff let's get one
pair of rooks off the board makes
defense easier and now I'll get this
pawn up my bishop could see the world
and let's target this I got to watch out
for Forks scary get my truck to a safer
Square pond oh I should just take in the
pond ah they didn't take it though oh
he's he's fast he is a fast piece take
that night and then push okay I have
this time back to tournament 170 oh he
dropped back it's not easy to win these
games oh actually somebody else jumped
up okay
let's go here this guy has negative 130
STR 103 is he just resigning every game
he's resigning every game yes what a
pairing well that was a good pairing
right there okay double the points no
Queen Knight 190 I might be running away
with it now after those last two
okay it's in full effect now let's do
that
prepping it it's being prepped right now
come on which pond okay let's go with
that one queenside castle doubling up
actually let me do this this is
different or better maybe is the no the
Knights track that's why I said it's a
cook tonight
oh he's cooked he's a cook tonight uh
watch out for the cook tonight's
variation Oh problems over here Knight
takes bishop brutal the Queen is close
to being trapped problems take the
knight it's free it's a freebie take em
he's still free tricks tricks everywhere
um take the knight he's still free take
the bait okay my LightSquared Bishop
needs to play and how is he gonna play
over here let's do this deflection or
something and hit the Queen what's the
clock situation it's okay over here hit
the H pun oh they're hitting my a pond
in the meantime he's got to go uh-oh
trouble can the bishop save the day it
might be able to automate no matter what
no matter how they block that's main
doctor tournament 210 171 to people at
171 I don't know if I'm gonna be caught
three minutes left I get one more in
unless they get three wins or something
cuz that's forty one-point lead right
now or not 40 100 you know what we're at
here be prepared for it no trades if I
have the win I'm just gonna do it just
for fun hit him with the blue
huh there we go I'm having too much fun
with the blue chicken gambit
there's your G - that's my safety net
that's my safety net oh it's very scary
over there - okay let's block it up here
blue chicken g5 mmm eh files are gonna
open up keep it closed I'm on the rookie
I don't know if I want to take I have
the H file get rid of the bishop get rid
of that bishop chop give a check oh no
no no no the Bishop's gonna block I mean
you take here let's do this now let me
take a look I could do it at any second
I might need to do it actually
I might have to pull the plug on this
one oh I got the Queen never mind
they were fearing it they kept thinking
I bet you they felt anxiety right there
they're like how is he gonna hit me with
the gambit I could do it again I could
do it again this game might not finish I
might have to do it just in time ooh no
what was that a mouse slip they might
resign here I got the Queen got the
Queen oh they're still playing on let's
go
Oh mate mate mate mate mate mate on each
to back to tournament 250 running away
one minute left
let's see if I could get one more win 59
58 57 56 here's the clock if you didn't
know look at what I have to stare at
okay get out of the way clock okay I
can't do this can I win really quick
though I got 45 seconds right here
and here we go tonight right here you
know you want to do it night right here
f7o
defense okay I want to get this square
maybe I have 26 seconds take it three
night I'm on Evan I got the rookie the
Queen's gonna block come back here pawn
push is good it's still good let's give
a check just for fun come back seven
seconds over here each pond
there's no time that's it three two one
it's saying it's complete
oh this pond is falling there's no time
though it so is my rook that's it
first place confetti give me that
confetti right at the end it's starting
to become a runaway but not for the
great majority of that one to 52:21 the
second - oh 118 games they had 20 20 18
okay so high teens and low 20s they're
for the top top ten there although I'm
mega king must I had a really good
tournament only 15 games in but I was up
there all right
good games